un phénomène maintenant qui enflamme les
adolescents au point que certains
décident même de prendre des cours
d'allemand
il s'agit d'un groupe de rock venu
d'outre-rhin tokio hotel elle son succès
entraîner d'autres formations dans son
sillage le rock allemand au sommet
olivier les nous à dominique bonnet
ils sont déjà na vainqueur avant le
concert
le groupe majeur de jeune fille mineure
est en france tokio hotel tous concerts
95 arraché en 48 heures on a eu du mal à
trouver les bases vu ça chez les cours
il chante bien ils sont beaux ils jouent
bien de la guitare et la batterie sont
géniaux qu'on les aime ils ont entre 18
et 20 ans
originaire du mac de boer en ex
allemagne de l'est
un phénomène qui l'ont fait et mais
l'allemand a plein de petits français le
jour de la rentrée le professeur pose
une question pourquoi tu choisi
l'allemand est souvent ils écrivent
parce que je connais tokio hotel
certains m'ont écrit parce que c'est le
pays de tokio hotel on va essayer de
voir les paroles pour comprendre un peu
les textes de leurs chansons et des
recettes ainsi donc ces atouts aussi
pour qu'on fera la retraite ou des
buffets je sais pas pour vous mais puis
c'est justement mon fiancé
il chante le malaise adolescent le
divorce des parents des troubles de la
sexualité
dans le sillage de tokyo hotel d'autres
groupes venus d'allemagne apparaissent
déjà notamment qui leur pile car c'est
bien connu quand on aime on ne compte
pas ce n'est plus une vague mais un
raz-de-marée venues d'outre-rhin